hey guys how's it going so as some of
you who have a lot of you have actually
tweeted me about the new announcement
that Apple's going to be releasing a
hundred new iOS emojis in iOS 10 and I
kind of avoided looking at it until I
saw one of the headlines that Apple
decided they were going to replace the
gun with a water gun I'm all for being
sensitive to sensitive topics and
subjects especially gun control but I'm
not sure if this is the solution to
world peace but that's that's what
they're doing so let's see what else
they're doing new it silence unbated 100
new emojis replaces gun with water
pistol
I am completely just unsure of how I
feel about it because I really am 100%
torn I'm not sure if this was a good
idea or a bad idea I really have no idea
that says they're gonna be releasing
more than 100 new or redesigned emojis
with iOS 10 this autumn here's every
single new emoji okay let's take a peek
new hairstyles it's got a female officer
we've got a female detective we've got a
female construction worker we have a
baby with wings my god I'm never gonna
be able to find all of these ones the
bride she looks very pretty sad phaser
okay my god it's gonna take you 45
minutes to figure out which family is
yours
we've got girl and boy boy and boy girl
and girl girl girl girl boy boy boy ah
these all look about the same boy boy
kiss boy girl kiss bro girl kiss I like
the purple that looks really cute strong
girl strong boy girl ball boy golf girl
mountain bike Oh a mountain bike for a
walk boy walk girl and boy boat at some
point like yeah this is quite excessive
this is my favorite the boy leotard
dancers
I like that skull is that that's new
that's definitely new I'll be using that
one quite often let's see if there's
anything else new I don't think I ever
did an actual video talking about some
of the iOS 10 up
it's going to be kind of cool and the
beta is out right now but I didn't want
to install it on my phone because there
were a lot of people having issues with
it as you can see here you can kind of
like click and add stickers and do all
kinds of really cool things in iMessage
but what's interesting is if you have it
now and somebody else doesn't have it
and you click that you like their text
message or their iMessage it'll just say
Justine like this message so it's
technically for them they don't see that
you liked it it just says that you like
their message could get a little
confusing it's also going to be
interesting because not a lot of people
update to latest os's
most of my friends do thankfully so at
least we'll still be able to have the
conversation they won't be like what are
you talking about well because I feel
like this is such a huge update with all
the integrations into iMessage it's
gonna be kind of hard with people who
don't do the update this is gonna be
interesting
invisible ink to send messages only
revealed after a friend swipes over it
that sounds a little risque redesigned
maps I never use Apple maps rediscover
memories and photos memories scans all
of your photos and finds favorites or
forgotten events trips and people that's
going to be kind of cool better access
an integration raised to wake
automatically wakes the screen as you
raise your iPhone a little something
like the Apple watch which is actually
charging right now see there's a lot of
new things coming I'm excited for
because I'm it's sad to say I'm bored of
my phone I feel like technology changes
so quickly now that to keep everybody
interested and and just not becoming
bored or stale of anything that's out
analogy like you have to be making
changes and making things that keep
people into it let's see what else the
people are saying about the new emojis
oh girl surfboard cute a rhinoceros a
real nice deer look at this a pregnant
baby a liar a drooling emoji clown is
this real or these lies I'm just never
sure scooter punch fencer peanuts
butterfly boy okay while juggling I'm
excited about the juggling a nice neck
are nice cucumber carrots red salad bat
owl duck pregnant belly that's a good
one
hi guys well thank you so much for
watching let me know if you have a
favorite of the new emojis that you've
seen or if there's something that you
think that
has failed to put in to this new emoji
set or any emoji set I'm also curious it
seems you guys think about the swapping
out of the gun for the squirt gun
I'm still pretty undecided not really
sure how I feel but either way that's
that so see you guys in the next video
bye sleek real slim